foreign the coronation on Sky News
followed the king's procession and the
service on TV an ultra high definition
and be part of the day with coverage on
the Sky News app and YouTube channel
also on TV and online my king my country
our documentary on what the future could
hold for King Charles III follow the
coronation all weekend on Sky News
it was very exciting all the bands that
went went down before the coach and then
this beautiful gold coach coming down
with the queen in it wonderful really
good day she was accompanied by Prince
Philip and was cheered to the Echo by
her the most magnificent thing for
Indian cavalrymen who had a giant head
here which they woven over their heads
and the rain has splashed down the poor
Devils were on roads and rows of horses
the people was crowded with royalty and
representatives from nations from all
over the world for the solemn ceremony
have transformed a shy young girl into a
queen be sure Winston Churchill that's
as the chocolate ass sort of Scotch egg
just a little bit inside his marriage my
Minister Churchill saw another page of
British history written in the
enthronement of Elizabeth II
Brian casteven and Julie Windsor have
many memories of Queen Elizabeth II's
coronation back in 1953 because they
were both there Julie was 12 at the time
her parents didn't have a TV so being
able to witness such an event in person
was a big deal for her
for Brian it was quite the adventure for
his 18 year old art student self we're
going to hear plenty more about their
stories on this podcast because not many
people still alive can say they'll have
witnessed the coronations of two British
monarchs one post-war the other
post-pandemic but King Charles big day
will be very different to that of his
late mother because Britain is a
completely different place now we'll
Explore More on all of that on this Sky
News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this is really a wedding between the
Monarch and the nation in some respects
and the Monarch and the church and I
think what's key here beyond all the
sort of flummery and the soap opera is
that our standing as a nation on the
international stage has changed hugely
and so too has our relationship with the
established church the church of England
historian Dr Tessa Dunlop joins me a
little later as we compare these two
Royal occasions but before we get there
let's take a look at Queen Elizabeth's
coronation Through The Eyes of a 12 year
old Julie who won a school competition
to go along
we had to write our names on a piece of
paper and it was put into a top hat
and the teacher pulled out two names
to go up to the coronation with the
school my name came out first actually
and it was so exciting I'd never won
anything that was a big big big day for
me and I was behind some other children
but I could see it well enough to take
quite a few photographs my mother had
got me a camera so I could take
photographs what photos do you have from
that that day that mean most to you I've
got the coach some of the army and all
the regalia that was going on at that
time I've got some pictures of that as
well suddenly this young woman who was
only 25 years old was going to be Queen
what do you remember feeling as a young
girl seeing that happen feeling sad for
her and that she was uh young and had to
take on that big responsibility really
World War II it hadn't ended by that
many years and the country entered this
period of austerity and economic
restraint what do you remember about
that did you feel that as a child at
that time things were getting easier I
must say as a child we I mean we didn't
have what they've got anything we didn't
have a phone I don't think then we
actually had a television I think we
went round to neighbors to watch big
things that were going on at the time we
had rationing I can remember my mum she
used to cut a coupon out of the Russian
book and it was very tiny little coupon
and used to go down to the sweet shop
and get a quarter of sweets things like
cheese and bacon you didn't get very
often
Julie also recalled having an outside
loo growing up and memories of playing
with friends in the street something she
feels kids don't really do these days
because of things like safety more cars
and Technology with screen time indoors
more than Norm
I had a friend and we decided we're
going on a tandem I soon realized I
wasn't going to cycle on a tablet with
him because he cycled under a tree and I
was stupid enough not to duck
essentially Brian and his friend also
caught Brian had originally set off from
Bath on a tandem bike he was on the back
seat and well ended up getting smacked
in the face by a tree branch when his
mate ducked and well he didn't the pair
ended up going back to Bath they got
separate bikes and then pedaled 100
miles or so through the night to London
suddenly we found we're on a piece of
land and people were beginning together
there but we went to one of the first
people it was probably somewhere near
Saint James's this is where we were
going to stay and the rain decided it
was going to stay the two Sailors it say
the uniforms and they decided some
member of the crowd around it was a
pickpocket so they did a sort of Naval
arrests on him and took him away there
we were left waiting for the programs to
go Ed Brian why was it so important to
you to see the coronation and have a
front row seat that you cycled all the
way from Bath to Central London
because I was young and just so I'm I'm
not going to be stuck here in bath
and people were going home to watch it
on television and I thought wouldn't it
be better to get on a bike and go to
London and watch it from London but it
was memorable very memorable thing to do
Brian was old enough to remember the end
of World War II just eight years earlier
it's a boy I was near
where Barry head which was near Torquay
and the man came out from the Coast
Guard Station and it was the end of the
war with Japan and he said we've just
had
the message it's arrived at our station
we've not passed it on yet you're the
first person we've seen so that was an
epic situation to be there and to be at
the end of the war reported personally
before Winston church with you wow so do
you believe you knew the war had ended
before Winston Churchill did it am I
understanding you correctly
yeah I I was told that I was the first
boy to know at the end of the war
because there's intercepted the message
uh very head wow whether that was true
or not I believe it
Brian's childhood was tough he was sent
to boarding school just a few weeks
after losing his father in World War II
now at 87 with white hair and wearing a
smart red checked shirt he spoke to me
from his care home in York where he now
lives and he's grateful for the options
he's had in life I feel sorry for
anybody who's in the royal family you
know because I feel
they having the choices I've had
their lives are planned in a moment a
look at then and now as we compare
coronation's country and Commonwealth
Elizabeth unimpeachable beautiful
innocent young female was this
extraordinarily fresh package in an
instant institution and shielded from
the cameras Dr Tessa Dunlop is a
historian she's also written the book
Elizabeth and Philip about the late
Queen and her husband
that idea of her having this
relationship this anointing with God I
think resonated for what was really
still a pretty deferential Britain a
still large number of people were
churchgoers very very different from
today things have changed unrecognizably
in the last census under half of
Britain's ticked the Protestant box let
alone the Anglican box so this idea of
the defender of the faith and that
relationship has changed hugely and I
think we have to recognize therefore
this has a less emotional impact partly
because of the person herself being so
young and innocent and seemingly
vulnerable and partly because of that
relationship we now have with the
established church or rather don't have
socially and politically the backdrop is
so different now from in 1953 remind us
paint the picture of the last coronation
and and just what was going on in
post-war Britain and this brings us onto
the you're arguably the biggest issue
which was Britain's position on the
global stage in 1953
on something of a Crossroads but still
although of course there were the two
twin pillars meat and housing Churchill
back in power ever worried that we
didn't have enough of either which was
true we didn't we had a dire balance of
payments deficit we also had issues with
rationing but actually a lot of
Britain's problems stem directly from
World War II which in terms of our soft
power had seen us yes financially
crippled but actually in some ways
temporally politically emboldened so
there were issues but there was also
exciting transitions Empire to
Commonwealth deference to democracy and
somehow casting some of these ideas
through this young prism of a feminine
Queen really added to the magic of the
event Churchill was adamant this was
going to be a big deal yes wait 18
months after her recession get the
bailiffs out of the house but we need to
go Blockbuster on this and of course
television added that extra exciting
post-war Tech Pizzazz it brought the
event not just to the people of Britain
but further afield to parts of the
Commonwealth a lot of course didn't have
tele across vitally to America now if
you flip that and look where we are
today things are very very different
arguably our cost of living crisis
um very low productivity in relation to
other G7 countries are loss of soft
power not just post-war but more acutely
in the wake of brexit Etc cannot be
temporally pinned on a wall so Britain
in other words has slipped on the
international stage vitally it's
important to understand that very
shortly after the coronation she went on
this
ping record-breaking Commonwealth tour
that went on for six months she stowed
her coronation down into the boat of the
ship and off she went with her dashing
war hero husband
one third of Australia turned out to Raw
at their Queen
can you imagine that today Sally things
have changed and and just what impact
did the Queen's Ascension have you know
her marriage to Prince Philip this young
glamorous couple what impact did that
have on the country and internationally
Elizabeth and Philip embodied two ideas
that their generation believed in we
talk nowadays about identity politics
and it's all over the shop what is your
identity you know there's so many
different versions of identity in
Britain today but back then they spoke
for their generation and for the masses
who were returning from war eager to
shed their uniform and crack on with an
optimistic piece and they weren't alone
Elizabeth and Philip LED an
unprecedented crash down the aisle so in
1947 more couples got married at a
younger age than ever seen before in
peacetime Britain nearly half a million
couples over 400 000. so they were bang
on Trend and they spoke for the young
for the future through no fault of his
own in many respects the same cannot be
said for Charles and the other thing is
the marriage of Elizabeth and Philip
was seen to be critical to their role as
members of the royal family this was
branded really the house of Windsor as
the country's first family that was
1950s Britain there was a a royal
commission into marriage and divorce in
1954 such was the clamor for some
couples to want to get divorced but they
couldn't afford to and actually they
came down heavily the commission on the
side of marriage the divorce laws would
not be reformed until late 1960s so it
was very important that Elizabeth and
Philip was seen to be this successful
marriage this unit functioning idealized
marital unit how much tougher do you
think it's going to be for Charles and
Camilla it's almost not comparable
obviously parts of the service will be
the same
that the venue's the same the ideas the
Traditions will be slightly adapted but
but the idea of anointing and a hair
down homage Etc
but actually the times we live in and
the way in which we now choose to or
choose not to identify are monarch has
been
irrevocably altered
by the 1980s half the population are
getting divorced but yet when Diana and
Charles trundle down the aisle in Saint
Paul's there's this kind of idea oh look
we're having another fairy tale wedding
you know it's just going to go on as
before the royal family how could it
possibly with the pressures of the
modern era in many respects they were
being set up to fail and I don't think
that we can remove ourselves from that
narrative and certainly in commonwealth
countries where they haven't been fed
um a rebranded Camilla in the way that
we have because our Tableau press have
got on side with Camilla over the last
couple of decades they've very much
still hold on to the Diana narrative and
I think that makes Camilla a harder sell
in many of their foreign Realms and
certainly it's it makes her a more
challenging cell in parts of Britain who
want that idea of an unimpeachable
Monarch instead we have an Everyman
Monarch which arguably much more
reflects our times but do we want the
Monarch to reflect our times isn't why
we loved perfect little Elizabeth
precisely because she was so idealized
and untainted it's interesting you know
that moment where the decision was taken
that the coronation had to be televised
for some reason and I don't know why it
became sort of like a myth that Philip
was behind that idea he was the one that
pushed it on the coronation commission
that's Buncombe Philip wasn't the the
modernizer um in this instance it was
actually the Press who thought God damn
it if we're going to be spending all
this money on on a coronation we want to
see it this is the people's coronation
it was a Winsome idea because it
combined ancient tradition with
cutting-edge technology there was a kind
of magical argument I don't know Sally
but you must have relations in your
family who remember running to their
nine inch television screen sharing that
moment with their nearest and dearest
and their neighbors and therefore
sharing that moment with their Queen so
there was this kind of literal bonding
idea of togetherness that can never be
replicated today because we're all
seeing everything on television today
that that's gone that magic that was in
that moment unique for its time in
contrast today we have God damn social
media and that the difference is
it can't be curated it's outside of
their control the queen to an extent
because of her great age because she
became this National Treasure I think we
forgot how unpopular the royal family
was in the 90s with all the Diana
tragedy in the divorces Etc if you think
about the reverence we saw that the
unconditional outpouring of love we saw
at the time of her funeral for this
exceptional woman most mainly
exceptional because of course the
position she'd occupied so to an extent
she was allowed to dabble rather
wonderfully with zooms and Tech you know
and occasionally popped up on our
screens but actually the vitriol that
other members of the royal family have
faced she was protected from King
Charles is having a very paired down
coronation this time trying to obviously
reflect the cost of living crisis there
is a conundrum about how much you spend
because you want it to have the wow
factor because otherwise what's the
point the last coronation on the
continent and remember all the other
great Royal houses came from Europe the
last one was in 1922.
um it was Queen Marie and Ferdinand of
Romania and this was because Romania had
doubled in size during World War One and
wanted to let everybody know that and so
they had this thumping great coronation
in 1920. that's the last one and so why
does Britain keep doing this and if you
are going to do it and it is going to
cost x million we're not going to know
the full cost until after the event by
the way it's got to be impressive but if
you don't spend money it can't be
impressive so it's like a sort of
Catch-22 the ultimate conundrum and I
think that's a very difficult Circle to
square there's going to be far fewer
people in The Abbey they packed in over
8 000 people like it wasn't covered
times in The Abbey in 1953 there's gonna
be 2 000.
um little more than 2 000 in in
Westminster this time so that's very
different 2 000 people rattling around
Westminster Abbey this time yeah Sally
we've also had
but quite a lot of sort of jubilees and
celebrations and funerals there is I
think a bit of Royal fatigue almost how
many times can we wave a Union Jack
don't forget we've had a glut you have
golden then you've had Diamond then you
had Platinum jubilees then you had the
funeral to end all funerals after
Charles's coronation say he lives very
unlikely given the average lifespan of a
of a male today in Britain but say he
lived another 25 years it would be that
long before we have a silver jubilee I
do Wonder once things die down how
Camilla and Charles broaden the appeal
of monarchy because it's gone from
polling it about 86 in the 1980s
dropping to 69 in the 1990s and then
hovering at around 55 just before the
queen died that's 55 of people who are
pro or a bit Pro the monarchy that
leaves a large number of people who are
either anti or ambivalent what I hope
for the coronation is that it matches
and encourages people out of that
ambivalence but I'm not sure I've seen
any signs it's going to yet we've
already seen uh Charles make moves to
try and modernize the monarchy how how
do you think he's going to try to adapt
things for modern times
that's a million dollar question I'm
alone in this by the way but I was for
example a little bit disappointed with
their selection of honorary page boys
for the coronation they're pretty much
all relatives or friends of the family
and recruited out of white upper class
England not even Scotland or Wales
people see through tokenism but Charles
has been waiting a long time to assume
the mantle of monarchy and I and I would
like to see something broader more
diverse more inclusive he has the
princess trust he is in so much of what
he does quite an inclusive man but we
need to see that represented in the
household still Buckingham Palace under
10 of their employees recruited from
ethnic minorities when London is over 40
percent ethnic minority so there are
things that for me don't quite Stack Up
it can't be that difficult
um and I think obviously the Megan and
Harry issue that that's that's a big
deal we need our monarchy to work for us
overseas that's one of the reasons why
we fund it is because it's this
incredible emblem of soft power beyond
the coronation it's a real chance to
extend ideas of britishness and British
Goodwill and I think the royal family
need to in some way better represent the
country that they come from because
we're not this crusty old former Empire
it's a cool place to be Britain do you
think we'll ever see
another coronation like this again the
royal family as we have known it as this
popular
brand running right through the spine if
you like of 20th century early 21st
century Britain I'm not sure it's set to
continue skating on much thinner ice
than it was
I think when an institution doesn't
speak for the majority in the same way
then it makes
um ideas of wrapping nationhood around
that institution harder to justify so
will William and Kate be coronated I'm
50 50 on that he might just get a hand
on the head as I think it says Norwegian
counterpart gets
while there's no front row seat for
Brian or Julie this time round they
along with thousands of others around
the country have some plans closer to
home where I live we've got two parties
that weekend
I've got my crowns already and what does
Brian think about the king's future
Andrew Charles yes
I don't know what will happen
my thanks to Tessa Dunlop Brian cast
even and Julie Windsor and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Sally Lockwood this episode was produced
by Annie Joyce with Alex Eden our editor
is Philly Beaumont and if you can hang
on for a brief moment we want to tell
you about a new Sky News podcast about
Queen Camilla
from the moment Camilla Parker Bowles
became front page news I need you all
week all the time oh God I'll just live
inside your trousers or something but
it'll be much easier what are you gonna
turn into a pair of knickers in a
scandal that rocked the world you've got
Prince Charles saying he wants to be a
tampon inside Camilla humiliating proof
of her affair with Prince Charles I have
no idea how Camilla coped with the
nastiness and the Relentless abuse but
together Camilla and Charles's love
survived they've surmounted all of that
and they have a true love her reputation
repaired that turn around in perceptions
of her is remarkable given just what a
low base Charles and Camilla were on
Diana was calling Camilla a Rottweiler
and now to a new role beside the new
king this rain will depend for its
success in no small part on Camilla I'm
K Burley and from Sky News this is Queen
Camilla For the Love of Charles a new
podcast charting a roller coaster ride
to becoming Queen of the Commonwealth